The Joe Rogan experience.
Do you see that male who identifies
as a female just broke all these world
records in weightlifting? The
new one just came out. Wonderful.
Congratulations.
Everybody broke everything.
Fucking so progressive and so
preposterous that we broke everything.
You have men that are women when women's
world records in fucking weightlifting,
which is like the dumbest shit I agree
for men and women compete against.
If there's ever one thing, even though I
like the tennis argument, it's like, well,
you know Billie Jean King
beat Bobby Riggs. Yeah,
but Bobby Riggs was 55 she was 29 and
they say that he threw the match because
he bet against himself. I'll write. He
was a big gambler. That was what I heard.
But yeah, I would say that
too of I lost. Yeah. You know,
let's say I threw the match. Yeah. Well,
yeah. Basketball is 10 is this the woman?
The One? Yes. Says Chelsea, this is, uh,
the women who's winning is not Bruce
Jenner records. Okay, let's get a look.
Oh my goodness. Here we go.
It seems like I go, Huh?
That seems like a very strong man.
Yes. So how much weight is
that? It doesn't look very
a lot of weight. It's like,
oh, this, this is all about,
this is about reps here.
300 303 15 yeah. I'm like, okay,
that's a ridiculous amount of weight for
a woman to lift to [inaudible] for if
you're going to be a real woman,
biological woman, excuse me,
and lift that kind of weight. You have to
be a real outlier. Yeah. It's very rare.
Yeah, but this is so ridiculous.
Wow. Oh, what is this? This is,
what does this guy's quote? What does
it say? One guy in the comments say,
congratulations on your
excellent performance. Screw.
Anybody who tries to knock achievements,
the hard work speaks for itself. Hey,
whoever you are, fuck you. Yeah,
fuck you and your nonsense.
You're the reason why this
shit is happening in the
first place because people
tolerate this and that is nuts.
If you,
if you had a daughter that trained her
whole life to be a weightlifter and she's
really into it and this
fucking guy decides,
he identifies as a woman and then
compete as a woman in weightlifting,
it's just fucking stop.
Everybody just stopped.
You're in crazy town. This is
officially crazytown. Yeah,
out of our fucking miles and how
it's legal, what is illegal? It's,
it has nothing to do with
being open minded or tolerant.
It has something to do with logic.
Just basic reason. This is craziness.
This is you're enabling people to
do something that's preposterous.
This is nothing to do with being
open minded are kind to people.
I'm 100% for people being trans.
I'm 100% for people doing
whatever they want to do.
Just don't hurt anybody and I'm cool
with that same Mary's, but this is just,
you're in make believe town.
Why not?
Pretend you're a fox and go
live in the forest you're in.
Make believe this is
make believe you can't.
You can't just decide you're a
woman and compete with women, right?
It's make belief you. Oh,
I, there's no advantage.
Make belief that's make believe it
is. Michael is an advantage. Yeah,
I fucking know there's an advantage.
Yes. Everyone knows this is crazy.
I want to uh, see that
in the NFL. You know,
you got like what does
that before and after?
Is it two different looks the same
day to see this person is sick.
I don't want to shame this person. Look,
someone's letting her do this. Right.
You know, it's nice. The problem.
That's the problem. They should sit,
there should be a transgender league,
right?
Or there should be some rules where you
have to compete with the chromosome,
your birth.
You don't have to fucking compete.
Most people don't compete in organized
sports. Most people don't know.
And if you're trans, maybe that
should be something you can't do it.
And particularly for girls
who transitioned to boys,
you know that school in Texas that won't
let this girl is transitioning to a boy,
they won't let her compete with boys.
So they make her compete with girls and
she's on fucking testosterone. Right?
So she's taking testosterone to be,
or he's taking testosterone,
whatever you want to say.
I get so confused. Yeah.
To become a board Zur is taking
testosterone to become a boy. Yes.
And then now is forced to
wrestle with women. Yes.
Young girls. Yeah. In fact, all
jacked. Right Jack? Like a boy.
It's like a boy wrestling girls. It's
crazy. Probably pop a boner doing that.
I don't think she has one yet. You can get
a little thumb. You grow a thumb. Yeah.
That's what happens. Oh yeah. Yeah. The
clearest gets a little bit bigger. Yeah.
And did the ovary sort of like start
getting suspended in a, I don't know,
they come to these drops.
What do they do?
No wonder the wonder that if they remove
those parts, you know, because they do,
hysterectomy is on women
when they have diseases.
And what if they do that when a man, when
a man transitions from a woman. Yeah.
When a man transitions from a woman.
Yeah.
When you used to be a woman and now
you're going into the dude. Yeah.
What do they do? I just can't wait til
the day where they can do it genetically.
Where a woman really becomes a woman,
like a man becomes a woman or a
woman becomes a man. But guess what?
Even if they do,
here's the issue.
If you knew that a woman took steroids
for 30 years and developed insane tendon
strength and muscle strength
and then stopped doing steroids,
it is a scientific fact that you are
going to keep a very big percentage of
those gains.
What are the games?
What is the percentage that 30%
or 40% whatever the fuck it is,
whatever percentage that you would
keep after you get off the steroids,
that is significant in,
even if you're not currently on
these performance enhancing drugs,
your body has been artificially boosted
to the superior level through these
drugs. Yeah. And you lose a lot of the
feminine and you lose the breast. Yes.
Does it might not come back? Um, well,
I mean I think if you take estrogen,
they'll probably call ray. I don't know.
I'm not a fucking doctor. I'm a moron.
I thought what I do know is when this
is, we're in nonsense land. Yeah, okay.
It's not, it's not saying that someone
can't become a woman and be a woman.
I'll talk, I'll call them a woman.
I'll treat him like a woman.
I'm cool with it and I'm 100% cool that
I'm in as open minded as I come with
this. But this is, this is
unfair for which is what's
so ironic about this. Yeah.
Cause everyone's supposed
to be looking out for women.
If you're looking out for women,
but you're also blindly progressive to
the point where you let and shit like
this fly, well now you're not
looking out for women. Right?
Because now women are in
this weird position where
you're putting them there at
an unfair disadvantage. Right.
Fucking crazy. I agree. Goddamn.
And it makes me want
to drink real Heineken.
I'm getting beyond this double zero.
No, they're just sent this stuff to me.
It's good. Yeah. Um, I used
to love Heineken light.
I talk about that subject a little
bit too much, but it's just,
it's a symptom of a sick society.
It's a symptom of a lack
of rational thinking.
It's a symptom of people just just
be being bending over backwards.
So hard to be progressive and
open minded that you're just,
you're giving into these extremists,
these crazy people that are looking
at this thing completely delusional.